this video is sponsored by Squarespace
in a recent short on my channel I made a
video explaining why I thought cold
showers were a little bit overrated that
turned out to be one of the most
controversial videos on my channel ever
oopsie Pepsi probably not by coincidence
though it was also one of my most
watched videos and because shorts really
don't allow for nuance I wanted to
expand on that point and explain why I
genuinely do think cold showers are a
little bit overhyped that isn't to say
they can't be beneficial for some people
and if you find them useful of course I
don't think you should stop doing them
but I wanted to explain why I think that
assessing all of the research out there
I stand by this point and it's not just
a hot take and I also want to explain
why I think that this points to larger
issues with biohacking in general and
why I think many of these Health Trends
and fitness Trends really are just bads
or perhaps a little bit overstated and
why we can't just extrapolate from one
or two studies or even a large body of
evidence and then say we need to engage
in this Behavior to get these results
it's rarely that simple when you look at
the broader context of your lifestyle so
let's Dive Right In I'm getting very wet
out here gonna head into the sauna
foreign
firstly if you do get benefits from cold
showers then absolutely you should keep
taking them there's more than enough
evidence to suggest that you're feeling
more than a placebo and so I wouldn't
want to ruin that for anybody this is
also not an attack on anyone I love
Andrew huberman I love Wim Hof the Wim
Hof method is awesome and cold exposure
can be really useful as we'll get to
later it's just the cold showers on
their own don't have quite as much
research backing them as you might think
the issue is more with the way that cold
showers are presented as this kind of
cure-all for everything and that if
you're not doing them then the only
possible explanation is that you must be
a wuss I really disagree with that and
you shouldn't feel bad if you don't get
any benefits from them because actually
like I say there's not a huge amount of
evidence to suggest that you necessarily
would in response to my sure a few
people said that I was obviously
ignorant of the research and I wanted to
make this video partly to demonstrate
that that's really not the case if
there's one thing you can rely on me to
do is to do all of the reading and all
of the watching on a topic like this
it's just that I've come to different
conclusions and I think that when I get
to the end of this video you might see
my perspective active so feel free to
disagree with me and obviously let me
know in the comments down below but
please do watch the video all the way
through before you make up your mind if
that's what you want to do and I think
this speaks to broader issues with the
whole concept of biohacking of looking
at a couple of studies that seem to
demonstrate something is unequivocally
good and then applying it to humans and
saying that we should do this all the
time every day without exception it just
doesn't really work like that as we're
gonna see
so I'll start by recapping what I said
in the short the benefits of cold
showers cold showers are really popular
because they're supposed to do
everything from improving your immune
system to raising testosterone to
burning more fat and increasing a brown
fat and raising your metabolism to
waking you up making you feel energized
in the morning to boosting your mood
reducing inflammation and enhancing
recovery just about everything you can
think of Under the Sun but although all
of these assertions are based on
research and studies there are some
issues with them as we're about to see
so let's start with the first firstly
the testosterone gains are questionable
research is limited and inconclusive
there are some promising studies but
they largely focus on Ice baths not just
cold showers and even those show
relatively small effects full body
immersive they're far colder they're an
entirely different story even one of the
studies that is most commonly cited is
evidence that cold exposure could
increase your testosterone actually only
showed a link between increased
testosterone in men with testicular
varicosceles this is a condition
affecting the blood vessels around the
genital region and it affects about 10
of men so if you're perfectly healthy
and you don't have this issue then
you're even less likely to see any
benefits from taking a really cold
shower another study found no link at
all so hardly conclusive
anyways to me all of these supplements
and hacks that aim at increasing
testosterone are a little bit misguided
anyways after all if you're increasing
testosterone within the normal range if
you don't already have some kind of
really low testosterone issue then
you're unlikely to see huge differences
to your muscle building to the way you
feel Etc people wanted to be more Alpha
and a lot of good marketing I think has
led to this kind of wild goose chase
people trying to raise their
testosterone and not really getting much
to shave for it do you like the
biohacker shades by the way I think they
make me look like Tony Stark
I am Iron Man
kind of love them so how about that
dopamine them commenters told me off not
talking about this that's where the real
value of cold showers comes in after all
studies show that a cold shower can
raise your dopamine levels by up to 250
percent and this effect lasts for hours
dopamine is the neurotransmitter most
associated with motivation and reward
and more of it generally equates to
Greater productivity and more alertness
one person who commented on that short
pointed out to me that dopamine levels
have been shown in one study to rise by
equivalent to the amount of dopamine
spiked by taking cocaine I pointed out
to them that this was kind of like
defeating their own argument because I
invite you to go and take a cold shower
and then make a note of how that feels
then go and take some cocaine and take a
note of how that feels do not take
cocaine I did not just tell you to take
cocaine now compare if there's any
difference I think you'll find that the
cold shower well maybe makes you feel
more alert it's not quite on the same
level as cocaine
but this study is actually one of the
most often cited as proof that taking
cold showers can massively spike your
dopamine and increase your alertness and
focus so I thought it was worth looking
into it a little bit further this is a
perfect example of how a study can be
taken out of context because the actual
study which I paid for and downloaded so
I could look at it properly you're
welcome wasn't even looking at things
like focus and productivity dopamine
wasn't the main thing they were studying
and of course yet again the study was
looking at Cold exposure via ice baths
not via cold showers as we said already
that's an entirely different thing and
whether the spike would be anywhere
similar in a cold shower is really not
self-evident at the same time that 250
percent might still sound amazing but if
we're logical about it and we really
assess the study we find out that it
doesn't necessarily point to all that
much because that dopamine increase was
found when looking at plasma levels of
dopamine that means the amount of
dopamine in the blood and this doesn't
necessarily point to a massive increase
in available dopamine that can affect a
brain function because the body he
produces dopamine in many different
areas and not all of these can affect
the brain because they can't cross the
blood-brain barrier furthermore what
dopamine is going to have a different
effect on you depending on what part of
the brain it's in and how many receptor
sites you have there so for example
another study found that caffeine could
boost dopamine levels by eight percent
in the striatum that's a specific part
of the brain associated with things like
focus and motor control so that shows us
how and why caffeine can affect things
like focus and that used positron
tomography to determine this it is
highly likely that with a massive Spike
like that you can have some impact on
your focus and your attention but it's
not as huge as we might think and
especially when we consider that things
like caffeine can also Spike dopamine at
the same time so can many other things
we engage in spending time with the
loved ones can increase dopamine sleep
can increase dopamine eating can
increase dopamine especially chocolate
having a warm bath can increase dopamine
so just because the study shows that an
ice bath can massively increase dopamine
not just in the brain and a cold shower
might be able to increase a little bit
perhaps in the brain that doesn't
necessarily mean we have to do it
because all sorts of things affect
dopamine levels and instead of like this
just can't capture the complexity and
the Nuance of how something like a cold
shower would fit into our lifestyle but
now if you take a commute to work and
you get into an altercation with a
fellow commuter if there's traffic if
you're stressed maybe if you stub your
toe or just feeling tired then that's
going to alter this neurochemical
cocktail that you work so hard to
cultivate it's going to affect it
similarly we can look at the studies
that show cold exposure may be a method
to increase Brown fat and thereby to
burn fat Brown fat plays a key role in
generating heat and maintaining body
temperature this process is energy
hungry so Brown fat is rich in
mitochondria and can theoretically
increase fat burning and weight loss
some studies do show a potential link
between increased cold exposure and
increased Brown fat this makes sense
when you consider that brown fat is
there to keep you warmer it's a logical
adaptation to being cold more often but
again these studies focused on a much
more intensive form of cold Exposure One
study for example had participants
expose themselves to cold temperatures
for two hours at a time
but the issue is that once again this
isn't likely to make much of an impact
on your weight loss anyway studies show
that even as we increase Brown fat it
doesn't have much impact on calories
burned throughout the day if you're
going into this thinking it's a cheat
code for losing weight you're going to
be very much disappointed I rather
suggest focusing on diet and exercise
instead another big one for cold
exposure is inflammation and once again
many of the same issues persist those
being that the evidence isn't really
there and it's not necessarily an
unqualified net benefit even if it were
can a cold shower reduce inflammation
according to a study called can water
temperature and immersion time influence
the effects of cold water immersion on
muscle soreness the answer is yes but to
actually quote the study
cold water exposure can be slightly
better than passive recovery in the
management of muscle soreness so not
exactly a rave review and if you're
using cold showers to treat Doms delayed
onset muscle soreness then know that
this will also impair your hypertrophy
again there are studies to back this up
we know that ibuprofen for example can
prevent you from building muscle and in
a similar way because cold exposure
suppresses inflammation we need
inflammation to build muscle regular
cold exposure can decrease muscle
building this is mainly an issue if you
take a cold shower after a workout but
that's something to keep in mind and
that brings me to perhaps the most
controversial point from my short it
seems a lot of people are using cold
showers to strengthen their discipline
or something the theory goes like this
if you can force yourself to take a cold
shower you can train your discipline
like a muscle and thereby conquer
whatever challenge the day has in store
it's just like we all have that friend
who was unable to motivate themselves to
do anything they couldn't write that
book or start that workout program then
they started taking cold showers and
suddenly their life turned around before
we knew it they were running things
oh no wait a second that's not a thing I
think that might have been the film
Limitless if anything I think techniques
like this can be used as a form of
procrastination almost people convince
themselves that they're making progress
because they're taking cold showers or
reading some self-help book but they
never actually do the push-ups or the
writing or the work that would get them
the results
I perhaps made a mistake by choosing to
say that willpower is a finite resource
I was trying to explain that by forcing
yourself to take a cold shower every
morning you'd actually be using up your
willpower for the actually useful things
later in that day got some angry
responses as people reminded me you
could train your willpower and that the
notion of willpower being a finite
resource was no longer accepted owing to
some recent studies that cast out on it
in fact it was pretty strange just how
upset people got at that idea you come
out with
think like that poop
out
of course if I were to give you some
money out of my wallet would that ease
the pain but I think wording aside this
does hold up firstly let's be fair
because there's also no consensus that
discipline can be trained like a muscle
there are plenty of people who say that
and there are some studies that suggest
this is possible but there are equally
several studies that show it isn't the
general view being that we need more
research so let's not throw stones in
glass houses one paper discussed a large
multi-site study that attempted to
replicate the effects of self-control
training on various self-control tasks
profound nuclear evidence supporting the
idea that training self-control led to
improvements in self-control performance
in fact this whole idea comes from the
strength model of willpower that was
proposed by Roy balmeister and
colleagues the idea is also predicated
on the idea that willpower can be
depleted or exhausted with use otherwise
what are we training to improve right I
suspect that what's actually going on
here is that people can learn to use
certain coping techniques metacognitive
strategies that overcome difficult
challenges and they can practice this
this is a useful skill and one that
would likely result in new neural
Pathways forming over time so yeah it
holds up the notion that discipline can
be drained over time is essentially
what's known as decision fatigue this
itself is a subcategory of ego depletion
and while it's true that the concept of
ego depletion has been called into
question it is by no means definitively
false and I think it just makes a lot of
common sense will power and focus take
energy energy is finite you're
significantly less likely to engage in
extra work of an evening if your day
proceeding was particularly tiring and
stressful likewise I feel that forcing
yourself to have a cold shower is
actually just putting yourself through
an unnecessarily unpleasant experience
first thing in the morning making the
whole day feel harder now I know this
isn't true for everybody some people
told me they love taking cold showers
but I put it to them that they are no
longer training willpower in that case I
train my willpower all the time every
time I go to the gym and complete that
last rep I can use the same
metacognitive techniques there so I'm
already training my discipline it
doesn't need more training and certainly
not right before I actually want to use
it my day starts at 6am with changing
nappies making breakfast playing with
the kids I then only have like 10
minutes to get ready for work and at
that point I just want to have a nice
warm shower not everything has to be
hard not everything has to be an example
of how tough you are it is fine to just
relax and indulge sometimes in fact it's
necessary for Optimum performance so
give yourself a break you're still a
tough guy I promise another area where
cold showers could be beneficial is in
boosting the immune system but again
it's complicated we know that cold
exposure increases the production of
white blood cells however these studies
once again are conducted using full body
cold water immersion
do
that
[Music]
as far as actual cold showers go I could
only find one study that produced the
direct link this study relied on
self-reports which of course aren't
terribly reliable
I probably deserve that this study found
a 29 reduction in self-reported sick
leave which does sound good until we
consider that the same study found no
difference in actual incidents of
illness yet it is often cited as proof
that cold showers boost immunity they're
also promising studies looking at the
use of saunas and sauna baths so it's
possible that a regular hot shower or
bath could theoretically improve
immunity too so whilst cold exposure
could definitely be beneficial for our
immunity I don't think 90 seconds of
slightly cold water in a shower in the
morning is going to make all that much
difference and this is one of my issues
with biohacking more broadly we look at
some studies we'll look at some evidence
and we say x Behavior or X supplement
causes why benefit so we must be doing
it how could we not be doing it and no
matter how robust the data no matter how
good the studies and how many of them
there are even if it's unquestionable
you just can't do everything and just
because something can be beneficial for
you doesn't mean you have to do it
doesn't mean that it's going to change
your life or change the world vegetables
extremely good for you nobody questions
it but you don't see very many Tick Tock
posts or Instagram reels about
vegetables because they're just not sexy
and there are so many of these biohacks
now whether you're lying on a spiky mat
before bed whether you're wearing a blue
blocking Shades before bed whether
you're exposing yourself to red light
therapy whether you're taking saunas
whether you're having cold showers
whether you're meditating for 10 minutes
or having power naps and all these
things might be great but ultimately if
we chase after all of these things
that's supposed to do us wonders we're
going to end up like some kind of person
with OCD or perhaps on before a football
game with all these different Traditions
they have to fill out we're gonna have
to spin around in a circle three times
turn the light switch on six times eat
half an orange and then scrub our
eyeballs with some kind of powder and
then go to bed and then do it all again
there's just not enough time in the day
to do all these things likewise with
supplements sure this supplement
increases magnesium sure this supplement
increases brain plasticity so there's
this one and this one this one's a great
adaptogen which is really good for
combating stress and this one increases
l-theanine this one increases serum
toning great for your feel good hormones
this one's great for energy metabolism
this one's great for hypertrophy but if
you take all of them you'll be spending
an absolute fortune on different
supplements and trust me I know there's
countless supplements that I highly
recommend they're all fantastic Lion's
main mushroom omega-3 fatty acid vitamin
D they're all fantastic but you can't
take all of them so it's much better to
just eat a balanced diet and remember
that all these things are just five
percent improvements 10 improvements if
that usually a 0.1 Improvement that you
could get from doing something else and
that's why I don't think we can be
chasing after every single thing that
sounds great on paper but in reality
isn't going to make a huge difference to
your life other than to just spend an
awful lot of time but I don't want you
to take all this as me completely
disregarding the usefulness of cold
exposure that's not what's happening
here at all so with this I haven't even
managed to get the temperature as cold
as you should do for real ice bath but
it's still definitely really cold and a
shock to the system it's entirely
different than a cold shower what I
really like about stuff like the Wim Hof
method is that you're shocking your body
you're creating this adrenal response
and then trying to control your nervous
system to get that under control and to
cope with it this is hard work by the
way that's something I'm really
interested in and Wim Hof will combine
cold showers with his breathing
techniques to achieve something similar
but the cold shower on its own really
isn't going to get you there to the same
degree some commenters said to me that
Batman would take cold showers and so I
should just do it as well but I say nah
Batman would meditate under a waterfall
this isn't just a hack that anyone can
try to squeeze into their day though
this is a practice that you need to
cultivate and work out just like
anything else and unfortunately for a
lot of people taking regular ice baths
unless you've got somewhere local that
offers it it's just not super practical
filling this thing up took me forever it
took bags of ice which still weren't
enough and yeah just the sheer amount of
water you'd be using means unfortunately
it is off limits for most people and
whilst it's certainly cool to be able to
control your nervous system I don't know
that it's something that literally
everybody needs to be doing
let's take the plunge
[Applause]
foreign
ly I tried cold water exposure at
Bournemouth beach in January that was
three degrees that was much closer to
what a realized bath should feel like
and that was after going in a really
really hot sauna you'll be able to see
why I was doing that very soon
imagine putting whole body in there that
wouldn't be
enough
it wasn't
all the nicest all the ice is melted
though cold showers on their own
practice for a few minutes aren't going
to teach you to master your nervous
system this is another reason I raised
my eyebrows at this whole expose
yourself to hardship Spiel this isn't a
bed of hot coals it's mildly annoying at
best likewise true cold exposure can be
very beneficial when combined with heat
exposure via a sauna again this isn't a
hack though it's an actual practice or
lifestyle change that takes time and
effort like training so yeah for all
these reasons I maintain the cold
showers are a bit overrated sorry cold
exposure is great when it's an ice bath
even better when combined with the Wim
Hof method but this takes time and
research and uses a biohack to quickly
improve your productivity your mood your
weight your testosterone the effects of
a 90-second cold shower isn't going to
be huge most of us don't have time to
set up an ice bath at home on a regular
basis
especially when we're also supposed to
be getting 10 minutes of red light
exposure and 10 minutes of sauna and 10
minutes of meditation it's just a bit
out of touch we need to pick what's
going to have the biggest impact the
biggest bang for the buck and probably
what's fun as well and usually that
means the basics it means exercising it
means sleeping right and it means eating
well the rest are just bonuses if we
have time if you don't have the
discipline to stick to your workouts
don't beat yourself up try making your
workouts more fun maybe look at your
lifestyle and ask why you're so tired
and demotivated to begin with try making
your workouts easier try being kinder to
yourself the aim of this video was never
to dissuade anyone who finds cold
showers genuinely useful individual
differences are huge and if you have low
dopamine or a high number of receptors
in the right areas if you have low sperm
production or you just like the feeling
of cold water then that's all great
everybody should probably try this once
but I wanted to make this video because
this has gotten out of hand people
preaching the cold showers can 10 times
your testosterone burn fat and fix your
depression are intentionally or Not Over
selling it and this idea that cold
showers are indisputably amazing for you
so you're just being a wuss if you don't
take them it's just wrong and misguided
maybe we shouldn't take ourselves so
seriously maybe we shouldn't take
showers so seriously I hope you found
this video useful and interesting guys
if you did please leave a like I imagine
it's going to get a bit of flack so it'd
be great to balance that out if possible
if you want to see more like this then
please subscribe and if you're
interested in using training methods and
other strategies that can improve every
aspect of your performance from strength
to Mobility to cognition then you might
enjoy my ebook and training program
super functional trading 2.0 the protein
performance system there's a link to
that in description down below it's an
80 plus page ebook and over two hours of
instructional video either way thanks so
much for watching this one guys and I'll
see you next time
bye for now
so this video was sponsored by
Squarespace for those of you who don't
know Squarespace is a website building
platform that makes it extremely easy
for anybody to build a fully functional
website you don't need to know how to
code you don't need any experience it
makes it extremely simple to build
something functional that also looks
modern and attractive and it will work
on any device you can literally have a
website up in minutes but at the same
time Squarespace is used by some of the
biggest brands on the web because it's
endlessly expandable just some of the
features include formatting tools you
can write blog posts you can schedule
posts for later there's a fully
integrated commenting system with
threaded comments likes and replies you
can manage your community thanks to tons
of membership settings and features
integrate social media so that your
posts display directly on your website
and generate Revenue thanks to members
only gated content here's the powerful
e-commerce tools to sell products
directly from your website and if you
need more features then Squarespace will
let you add a huge number of different
plugins to essentially enhance the
features of your site freecomers for
example that means everything from
accounting to global Shipping to
inventory management wherever you need
there's a plug-in for it if there isn't
already the feature built in head over
to squarespace.com if you want to learn
more or head to squarespace.com forward
slash bioneer if you're ready to get
started and if you follow that link then
bioneer viewers will also be able to get
10 off of their first website or domain
thanks again to Squarespace for
sponsoring this video
bye for now